we moved to Nashville about two years
ago and have grown to love the city and
the community here but when I found out
that my local Hospital Vanderbilt drugs
and mutilates kids uh I knew that that's
not something we could tolerate I don't
really want to share this city with
groomers and butchers the town isn't big
enough for both of us you might say so
we decided to investigate the hospital
and I admit that I'm no journalist but
if the actual journalists aren't going
to do their job then it falls to me and
to others on the right like Libs of tick
tock and Christopher and others who have
been working to expose the horrors of
gender ideology and as we dug into this
a story began to reveal itself yesterday
on the show I sort of told you that
story took you took you through it
chronologically started in 2018 with the
unveiling of Vanderbilt's new
transgender clinic and they were
motivated to get into the gender
transition game in large part because of
all the money there is to be made from
it
which in and of itself is maybe not a
revelation that they like making money
from this
but it was still interesting to hear the
video that we played of a doctor
boasting about the profitability of
transition surgeries quote unquote she
excitedly declared that bottom surgery
for women which is the construction of
an artificial penis using skin peeled
off of the arm or elsewhere on the body
is such a big quote Money Maker that
some clinics can Thrive financially just
by performing those surgeries alone now
why are they such a cash cow though well
because as she says they're they're
labor intensive and also because they
require lots of follow-up so yes if you
if you get one of these surgeries
you will be doomed to a life of
continued hospital visits as doctors
work to keep your fake sex organs
nominally functional uh it'll be
miserable for you I mean you have signed
on to be a patient forever
but it's great for the doctors of
Vanderbilt I mean they love it
next we revealed the intimidation
tactics the hospital has used to keep
their staff in line because of course
you know they decided that they're going
to start doing this and not everybody's
on board with it not everybody wants to
butcher people and chop their be a be a
party to this chopping their
um their you know bodies apart and
creating new sex organs and all the rest
of it
and Vanderbilt knew that not everybody
was on board so according to one video
we played staff were warned that if they
conscientiously object or if they
exercised their religious liberty their
first amendment rights and declined to
participate in these procedures quote
there will be consequences and if that
didn't get the message Vanderbilt also
enlisted an army of trans activists to
actually attend appointments with trans
patients to include children and conduct
essentially surveillance of the doctors
making sure that they're all affirming
of the trans identity
and then of course there's the Pediatric
gender Clinic which grew out of the uh
the the overall transgender clinic and
as I proved with video documentation as
much as we hear denials about this sort
of thing now uh the fact is that
Vanderbilt gives chemical castration
drugs to young children they prescribe
cross-sex hormones to 13 year olds which
are irreversible they perform double
mastectomies which are also obviously
irreversible on 16 year olds and they do
all of this
either on a mission
because there's a lot of money to be
made from it
now after I released our expose here on
the show and on Twitter yesterday
it caught fire fortunately my Twitter
thread with all these videos has been
retweeted over 30 000 times in a day and
counting state legislators here in
Tennessee have responded promising that
they will work to ban these practices in
the state our governor Bill Lee issued a
statement
saying in part that Tennessee quote
should not allow permanent life-altering
decisions that hurt children or policies
that suppress religious Liberties he
called for an investigation into
Vanderbilt there's been a response on
the federal level too Senator Marcia
Blackburn echoed the call for an
investigation the majority leader in
Tennessee in the Tennessee House of
Representatives William Lambert tweeted
quote I'm deeply troubled by what Matt
Walsh uncovered about the Pediatric
transgender clinic at vumc Governor Bill
Lee is right to call for an
investigation and we will support that
investigation 100 this type of child
mutilation should be illegal and soon
will be in Tennessee
I can also tell you that I've had people
within Vanderbilt contact me encouraging
me to continue exposing the institution
they work for and offering their help
from the inside
I've been in touch with many activists
and others here locally and across the
country wanting to join in the effort to
shut down Vanderbilt's child Butchery
business
now all of this of course has provoked
the expected reaction from the left they
aren't gonna
engage in any sort of discussion they
aren't going to attempt to defend
Vanderbilt's practices or explain why
it's actually good to chop an adolescent
girl's breasts up they're going to do
that they're going to justify
Vanderbilt's intimidation tactics
against their own health care providers
they aren't going to do any of that
because they can't instead they'll
simply try to have me silenced
and if they can arrange it Arrested too
so just reading through a sampling of
tweets from some verified accounts and
this again is just a small sampling
of what's out there but trans activist
Alejandra carabayo uh posted quote
Vanderbilt Medical Center has had to
shift medical appointments for its trans
Clinic to Virtual Telehealth
appointments as a result of threats
being made Matt Walsh is inciting a
terror campaign against a hospital and
disrupting care he will get people hurt
or killed
this of course is the common theme
you're going to get people killed you're
killing people
by factually reporting on what this
hospital is doing in a society of Rife
with anti-religious ideologies like the
ones where we we hear about from the
left on a daily basis it can be
incredibly challenging to ground oneself
in what we know to be true and good to
keep from descending and to distress
frustration and even hatred that's why I
find God's peace every day through
prayer and meditation with hallow hallow
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the U.S and the number one Catholic
app in the world is rooted in Catholic
tradition but it's an amazing resource
for any Christian looking to dive deeper
into their prayer life hallo has prayers
and meditations to guide you throughout
your entire day mourning tonight some of
the most popular prayers include the
Bible and a year with father Mike
Schmitz prayers led by Mark Wahlberg
Mario Lopez and Jim Caviezel they have
minute meditation meditations and much
more hallow helps me find peace and calm
throughout the day helps me sleep better
lowers my anxiety levels and has so many
other benefits as well but Halo help you
find your peace and strength throughout
the day go to hello.com Matt Walsh get
an extended three-month free trial
during which you'll have access to all
five thousand plus meditations and
prayers that's hello.com Matt Walsh for
three months free reclaim your piece in
this crazy world download hello today
Noah berlasky who's a bizarre freak
who's written for that creepy Pro
pedophile organization prostasia
um he tweeted uh crying out to Twitter
to shut me down saying Twitter support
how on Earth is Matt Walsh not violating
terms of service you are complicit in
terrorism and you're going to be
complicit in Murder if you don't take
action
this sentiment was echoed by Leah Torres
who's an abortionist who by the way um
if you maybe recognize the name from a
while ago she was the abortionist who
once bragged
about cutting the baby's vocal cords
during an abortion so she can't hear
them scream that's what she said
so she's she responded saying Matt Walsh
is off the rails and he is behaving
dangerously I reviewed his posts just
from today and he's going to get people
hurt and or killed I reported the post
but that hardly feels like enough
now of course coming from her accusing
me of getting people killed I can't even
tell if she means that as a compliment
she then tagged the FBI of course
because she wants to get the FBI
involved and so did a leftist creep
named Zach hunt who says Hey FBI and
justice department and mnpd Nashville
Matt Walsh is targeting Vanderbilt
Hospital the same way he targeted Boston
Children's Hospital please intervene
before one of his followers starts
calling in bomb threats or worse
this is the strategy they've of course
long since settled on
and it tells you everything you need to
know
because if there was any possible
defense of these practices
the left would make that argument they
tell us what the defense is
if there's anything they could say to
rationalize it they would say it
but there's nothing there's no defense
Vanderbilt like so many other hospitals
and medical clinics
is enriching Itself by permanently
damaging the bodies and minds of
children
it cannot be defended
so instead they cry incitement and hope
that the FBI comes and takes me away
what that means is that is that these
people at some level
they know that we are right
they know it
all the people responding FBI
they all at some level know
that they're the bad guys here
which makes them even a bit even bigger
bad guys makes it makes you even more
evil when you're aware of how evil you
are
they know that this is horrific and
inexcusable and they must recognize that
fact or else they wouldn't be so
desperate to shut down any conversation
about it
if they believe that Vanderbilt was
entirely in the right they would say
yeah Vanderbilt is doing all of that and
it's good thank you for the free
advertisements
no it as a as a comparison
the left likes to um talk about the the
evils perpetrated by pregnancy centers
you know and and of course they say all
these things about pregnancy centers and
then pregnancy centers are actually
physically attacked uh and there's arson
and and everything else but that's not
incitement
but here's here's the interesting thing
if uh if somebody on the left were to
post a long thread going through David
picking out any Pregnancy Center and
saying look at what this pregnancy
center does and then they post
an accurate description of all the
resources and all of the you know
practices of this pregnancy center
as a supporter of pregnancy centers I
would say great yeah that's exactly what
pregnancy centers do thank you for
letting people know please post more
like this
as an advocate and a supporter of
pregnancy centers I am proud of that
if you want to talk about pregnancy
centers we can definitely talk about it
I'm not going to try to shut you down
for talking about it
see that's what you do if you believe
you're in the right
if you believe you're in the wrong then
you you know literally call the police
and try to have me thrown in a jail cell
just for factually reporting about what
this institution is doing and who
they're doing it to
now as for Vanderbilt's response they
have so far issued No statement except
they did in effect issue a statement
when they took down their website for
their transgender clinic now when I say
they took down the website I mean the
whole site they deleted the entire site
getting rid of all the evidence
now unfortunately for them we
anticipated that and we spent uh the
previous week archiving saving videos
and taking screenshots so we have it all
it's too late to get rid of it guys we
have it
I mean what I posted yesterday talked
about the show that's only a small
fraction of what we have we have the
rest of it
but up until now I mean how do we get a
hold of this stuff because up until now
they were posting everything online with
Reckless abandon we didn't dig through
their trash or secretly film them to get
this footage
they filmed it and posted it
the footage of their doctor threatening
reprisals for conscientious objections
was streamed live to Facebook
and then published and posted there and
kept there for two years
same for the video of the woman
admitting to Vanderbilt's greed and
profit motives
streamed it put it on Facebook didn't
even take down the stream afterwards
they didn't even say to themselves oh
well she went uh he went a little off
script there with some of this I think
we're gonna take this down no left it up
there
for years these people did whatever they
wanted and they did it out in the open
without fear of pushback
or of criticism
but those days are over
they're over and they're never coming
back
so if you're in the gender Butchery
business you ought to know that
you operated with impunity for a while
but now that's done
I and I am not satisfied to Simply
report on what Vanderbilt is doing like
I said I'm not a journalist
I will act the part if I have to because
the real journalists won't
but I I have an opinion here I I have a
perspective
I have an agenda
the agenda is protecting kids
and exposing Horrors and atrocities
where they're happening
and the other part of the agenda is to
shut this down
okay we're gonna put a stop to it
we're gonna put a stop to it we're not
going to allow
this to happen to children we're going
to make this illegal
that's what happens next
and we're just getting started
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts